diane it's so good to see you
thank you for having me are you in
canada right now
i am i am i made it through my 14-day
quarantine bless this country for having
a good protocol
how is shooting going okay well you know
we're still in the
in the in the starting gate i mean
there's a lot more
uh i don't know what you call that
steps to to right into in front of the
camera so we're
we're not there yet but we will be very
shortly and i'm very excited
it's a lot of build up a lot of build up
in this movie i can't wait for everyone
to see it because as a mother it wasn't
easy to watch the idea of losing to the
child it really gets to you
uh for you to take on this role what did
it mean to
bring margaret alive and her her her
experience
of losing a child you know all the hope
then just
you immediately pour it right onto the
grandchild i mean the grandchild is
suddenly
eight times what the grandchild already
was
suddenly they're like a superhero to you
in terms of all of the potentiality of
your lost you know
shared your child so
generationally i mean this is this is
the final
stop of our dna and of our family ethic
and
and uh we would do anything anything for
him to fight anything as a parent
right yeah and for for me i was really
excited to see you and kevin back on the
screen together
did you call him and told him to take on
the role because you're taking on the
role and what was it like being all set
together again
uh in a word yes
[Laughter]
i listen you you don't you don't get
because you don't ask right so i thought
aim high man aim high and when he
nibbled i knew we had a
we had a real good screenplay i mean i i
knew what i felt
and i certainly wouldn't bring him
anything that i wasn't proud to
to say what do you think you know
they're there it's a very smart
screenplay it came from a wonderful book
and tom bazook is a great director
and screenplay writer so we were in good
we were in good hands with allstate here
and uh this film delivers up
a lot of surprise punches i mean it kind
of is
a little bit of everything i mean it's a
tough film but i think it fights
for kindness that's what i've been sort
of
generalizing it to for me i i forget how
all the all the ingredients i mean it is
a thriller and it is it is action-packed
and
all of that but i keep thinking about
how much heart it has because that was
the
yeah this for me to want to do it yeah
and there's a lot of action scenes too i
mean you pick up a gun there's a
slapping scene there's
fingers being cut i mean did kevin give
you tips on how to make that all happen
he's he's very uh skilled at uh
directing period as we know i mean
how many oscars did he get i don't know
a lot
so the point is yes he he knows
a lot about staging action sequences yes
and this is gonna be a crazy question
but there was a lot of talk about cake
that bundt cake had a few scenes and
i was like craving cakes so i have to
ask you what's your favorite cake
you know i'm not a i'm not a cake person
isn't that weird
no i mean i i guess coffee cake or
i don't know that bundt cake didn't look
good though
i was like can i eat the props yet when
can i eat the props
is the day over i want to eat that
you're so amazing in this film thank you
so much and enjoy
canada thank you i am already i can't
wait